a recently released American Iranian
journalist is urging people to join her
protests in Washington DC later on
Friday after she was held for ten days
in US custody earlier Marcia Hashemi
spoke to RT zaption return C about her
arrest
I was flown private plane option to DC
and then met with a whole lot of FBI
taken to the FBI heck take to FBI
headquarters I was my my picture was
taken mug shots they took my DNA the
owners ready the rights
no one is still yet and ready the rights
no one ever read me my rights I've seen
my rights were not read they said that
you're on suicide watch
I said suicide watch mmm I mean I'm
definitely not gonna kill myself I tell
you what it concerned me after she
because I'm thinking well you know maybe
they have something up their sleeves
here most of the time I was in solitary
okay I was locked up I couldn't come out
I remember once being returned coming
back from one of the court hearings and
all the prisoners were out and so I
enter and then the guard stopping no and
then all the prisoners had to get back
through another door oh they couldn't be
close to me Marcia Hashemi who works for
Press TV was detained on January 13th
while visiting family in Missouri the
court of justice confirmed that she'd be
questioned by the FBI as a material
witness but didn't specify what the case
was the Iranian government as well as a
press freedom organizations expressed
their anger and frustration over her
detention and before her release people
protested in Washington DC and Tehran
divining the journalists be let go
hosea hashem his family released a
statement saying the arrest was unfair
this was never just about Marzia Hashemi
this is about the fact that any of us
Muslim and non-muslim can be imprisoned
without charge in the United States my
son who was with me trying to get on
that flight in st. Louis and he did not
get on that flight in Denver which took
Denver which I had told him to because
the FBI was with him and accompanied him
the whole night though he was not under
arrest but fortunately he called my kids
my other kids if he hadn't been there
your children might might have just let
you disappeared
I've seen what I realize is how easy it
is for them to make someone disappear if
he was not there anything could have
happened to me no one would have known
where I was mind boggling that you can
be arrested detained shackled not
charged with the crime and Wow I
definitely saw it firsthand
well meantime the FBI has refrained from
commenting on the incident
you